so you talked about
diagnostics at scale as a possible
solution
to uh future pandemics what about
another possible solution which is
kind of creating a backup copy you know
i'm actually now
um uh putting together a nas for a
backup for myself for the first time
taking backup of data seriously
but if we were to take the uh the backup
of human consciousness seriously
and uh try to expand throughout the
solar system and colonize other planets
do you think that's an interesting
solution
one of many uh for uh protecting human
civilizations from self-destruction
sort of humans becoming a
multi-planetary species oh absolutely i
mean i find it electrifying first of all
so i got a little bit of a personal bias
when i was a kid
i thought there was nothing cooler than
rockets i thought there was nothing
cooler than nasa
i thought there was nothing cooler than
people walking on the moon
and as i grew up i thought there was
nothing more tragic than the fact that
we went from walking on the moon
to at best getting to something like
suborbital altitude
and just i found that more and more
depressing with the passage of decades
at just the colossal expense of
you know manned space travel and the
fact that it seemed that we were
unlikely to ever get back to the moon
level on mars
so i have a boundless appreciation for
elon musk for many reasons but the fact
that he has put
mars on the incredible agenda is one of
the things that i appreciate immensely
so there's just this sort of space nerd
in me that just says god that's cool
but on a more practical level we were
talking about
you know uh potentially inhabiting
planets
that aren't our own and we're thinking
about a benign civilization
that would do that in in planetary
circumstances
where we're not causing other conscious
systems to suffer
i mean mars is a place that's very
promising there may be microbial life
there and i hope there is and if we
found it i think it would be
electrifying
but i think ultimately the moral
judgment would be made that
you know the continued thriving of that
microbial life
is of less concern than creating a
habitable planet to humans which would
be a
project on the many thousands of years
scale but i don't think that that would
be
a greatly immoral act and if that
happened and if mars became
you know home to a self-sustaining group
of humans
that could survive a catastrophic
mistake here on earth
then yeah the fact that we have a backup
quality is great and if we could make
more
i'm sorry not backup colony backup copy
is great and if we can make more and
more such backup
copies throughout the solar system by
hollowing out asteroids and
whatever else it is maybe even venus we
could get rid of three quarters of its
atmosphere and you know turn it into
a tropical paradise um i think all of
that is wonderful now whether we can
make the
leap from that to interstellar trans
transportation
with the incredible distances that are
involved
um i think that's an open question but i
think if we ever
do that it would be more like
the pacific ocean's
uh channel of human expansion than the
atlantic oceans
and so what i mean by that is uh when we
think about
european society transmitting itself
across the atlantic
it's these big ambitious crazy
expensive one-shot expeditions like
columbuses
to make it across this enormous expanse
and at least initially
without all any certainty that there's
land on the other end right
so that's kind of how i view our space
program
is like big you know very conscious
deliberate
efforts go from point a to point b if
you look at how
pacific islanders um transmitted
you know their descendants and their
culture and so forth
throughout polynesia and beyond it was
much
more you know inhabiting a place
getting to the point where there were
people who were ambitious or unwelcome
enough
to decide it's time to go off island and
find the next one and pray to find the
next one
that method of transmission didn't
happen in a single
con swift year but it happened over many
many centuries
and it was like going from this island
to that island and probably for every
expedition that went out to seek another
island and actually lucked out and found
one
god knows how many were lost at sea but
that form of transmission took place
over a very long period of time and i
could see us
you know perhaps you know going from the
inner solar system to the outer solar
system to the kuiper belt to the oort
cloud
you know there's there's theories that
there might be you know
planets out there that are not anchored
to stars like kind of
hop hop slowly transmitting ourselves to
at some point we're actually an
alpha centauri but i think that kind of
backup copy and transmission of our
physical presence and our culture
to a diversity of you know
extraterrestrial
outposts is a really exciting idea i
really never thought about that because
i
i have thought my thinking about space
exploration has been very atlantic
ocean-centric in the sense that there
will be one program with nasa and maybe
private uh elon musk spacex or jeff
bezos and so on
but it's true that with the help of elon
musk
making it cheaper and cheaper more
effective to create these technologies
where you could go into deep space
perhaps the way we actually colonize
the solar system and
expand out into the galaxy is basically
just like
these like renegade ships of of uh
weirdos
that just kind of like like home like
most of them like quote unquote homemade
but they just kind of venture out into
space and just like
like you know the android the initial
android model like
millions of like these little ships just
flying out most of them
die off uh in horrible accidents but
some of them will will persist or
there'll be stories of them persisting
and over a period of decades and
centuries there'll be other attempts
almost always as a response to the main
set of efforts that's interesting
yeah because you kind of think of mars
colonization as
the big nasa elon musk effort of a big
colony
but maybe the successful one would be
you know like a decade after that
they'll be like a ship from like
some kid some high school kid who gets
together a large team and does something
probably
illegal and launches something where
they end up actually persisting
quite a bit and from that learning
lessons
that nobody ever gave permission for but
somehow actually flourish
and and then take that into the scale of
uh
centuries forward into the into the rest
of space that's really interesting
yeah i think i think the giant steps are
likely to be nasa-like efforts like
there is no intermediate rock well i
guess it's a moon but even getting the
moon ain't that easy
between us and mars right so like the
giant sat steps the
the big hubs like the o'hare airports
yeah of the future probably will be very
deliberate efforts
but then you know you would have i think
that kind of
diffusion as space travel becomes more
democratized and more capable you'll
have this sort of natural diffusion of
people who kind of want to be off-grid
or think they can make a fortune there
you know the kind of mentality that
drove people to san francisco i mean
san francisco was not populated as a
result of a
king ferdinand and isabella-like effort
to fund columbus going over it was just
a whole bunch of people making
individuals
decisions that there's gold in them thar
hills and i'm going to go out and get a
piece of it so
i could see that kind of fusion what i
can't see and the reason that i think
this specific model of transmission is
more likely
is i just can't see a nasa-like effort
to go
from earth to alpha centauri it's just
too far i just see lots and lots and
lots of
relatively tiny steps between now and
there and the fact is that there is
there are large chunks of matter going
at least a light year beyond the sun i
mean the oort cloud i think
extends at least a light year beyond the
sun and
you know then maybe there are these
untethered planets after that we won't
really know till we get there
and if our cloud goes out a light year
and alpha centauri's
cloud goes out a light year you've
already cut in half the distance
you know so who knows but yeah one of
the possibilities
probably the cheapest and most effective
way to create
interesting interstellar
spacecraft is ones that are powered and
driven by ai
and you could think of here's where you
have high school students be able to
build a sort of a hal 9000 version
uh the modern version of that and it's
kind of interesting to think about
these uh robots traveling out throughout
perhaps perhaps sadly
long after human civilization is gone
there will be these
intelligent robots flying throughout
space
and perhaps land on uh often centauri b
or any of those kinds of planets and uh
and colonize sort of
humanity continues through the
[Music]
proliferation of our creations like uh
like robotic creations that have some
echoes of that uh intelligence hopefully
also the consciousness
you